[Music]
china's in the middle of four different
outbreaks when it comes to coronavirus
and that's because of the delta variant
you'll remember that the virus first
emerged in wuhan in 2019. we all heard
the stories about how the government
there was building massive hospitals and
locking down entire sections of the city
but then we heard really nothing about
it after that the delta variant has
really changed everything across the
world and china is no exception it had
an outbreak starting in august that
spread across the country the broadest
outbreak since 2019. it did get that one
under control and got back to zero cases
since then however it's dealt with three
additional outbreaks that have cropped
up in different places across the
country all unrelated to each other this
is something that china's going to be
dealing with for quite some time
[Music]
china takes controlling coronavirus
really seriously it doesn't want to have
any of the pathogen within its borders
they're following what we consider a
covet zero strategy so every single case
that crops up within the country they do
testing and quarantining and isolating
to make sure that they have caught any
person who might be harboring the virus
now there are a couple of reasons why
china is doing this number one is
they're inviting the entire world in for
the beijing olympics that are starting
in just three months and they really
want to keep everything safe but more
significantly for china they can do it
they are so big and their economy is so
large that they can do everything that
they need to do
internally they don't really have to
open up yet and when it comes to the
safety of their people they have said
that they're willing to pay almost any
price to make sure that they're not
going to be leveled by coronavirus as
they were initially when the outbreak
first occurred and move on
it's really unclear what the endgame is
going to be for china when it comes to
coronavirus now they are the only
country that has isolated itself that is
still going after this elimination
strategy the problem is is that no one
else in the world is so once they do
finally open up they are going to be
letting down their barriers to a world
that's still awash in coronavirus even
though they have a vaccination rate
that's over 75 percent so eventually
they will have to deal with this
pathogen just like everyone else has
how they're going to do that though and
more importantly when they're going to
start doing that is something really no
one knows at this point we are expecting
that it will happen after the beijing
olympics but other than that it's just
an unknown
[Music]
you